let's continue following up on the ron
desantis martha's vineyard immigrant
stunt one of the biggest
i hesitate to call it a confusion
one of the biggest misstatements that's
being made about the entire thing is
that the 50 or really 48 migrants who
were flown to martha's vineyard by ron
desantis on the tax dollars of
floridians
the claim is being made that they are
here illegally when that is actually not
the case and the casual nature with with
republicans are now claiming this is
causing it to spread like wildfire those
migrants were not here illegally i will
explain that in a moment here is marco
rubio just one example he was on fox
news yesterday or maybe this was this
morning this morning in fact uh saying
these are folks who were here illegally
and of course they were not well think
about this okay people came into this
country illegally violating our laws no
okay and the first thing they do is get
lawyers and use our laws to sue an
elected governor that's after
they were lured
arguably illegally to get on a plane to
send them to martha's vineyard they are
only now suing and we will talk about
that lawsuit on the bonus show sue
estate i mean just think about that they
just got here they're not even here
legally they didn't enter the country
the proper way and they're immediately
in court demanding rights and claims
under our laws this is outrageous what
other country in the world would that
even be allowed what other country in
the world would even tolerate that so i
think this is you know we have a this is
not immigration what we're seeing okay
this is mass migration that's a very
different thing and and but to think
about the fact that somebody just came
here illegally and within a week they're
in court and they have lawyers
representing them in court well that's
thanks to ron desantis my friend suing
the american government that whose laws
they just violated is unbelievable it's
outrageous it angers me and it should
anger everybody so let's take this step
by step
the picture painted but the these
republicans lie constantly the picture
that rubio is painting
is
bunch of illegal immigrants come to the
us they're here illegally and within
days
they're using our court system to sue
others demanding rights and demanding
money
that could not be further from the truth
first of all as our friend anna
casparian tweeted quote asylum seekers
awaiting a decision from immigration
judges are not in the u.s illegally also
cubans like marco rubio who benefited
from amnesty after the revolution
rubio's family to be clear
should maybe be more considerate and
self-reflective when weighing in on
venezuelan migrants
so
when you think of the story that rubio
tells
illegal immigrants for no reason using
our courts to demand stuff well first of
all they're not illegal immigrants when
you are
awaiting an asylum decision
you are here
legally in the sense that you are
pending a legal decision now asylum is
discretionary meaning sometimes
individuals claim asylum and it is
denied to them even if they technically
meet the definition of refugees this has
to do with the adjudication but when you
do the right thing you come to the
border you request asylum it is awaiting
a decision you are not here illegally so
the first piece of rubio's story here
illegally
for no reason just filing lawsuits
actually not here illegally the second
part is the civil suit that has now been
filed by these migrants who are not here
illegally
has only been filed
because of what ron desantis did
ron desantis is now under criminal
investigation the state of florida and
the desantis administration under
criminal investigation
for what
is tantamount to human trafficking they
lied and deceived these migrants
lured them to get on these planes saying
you're going to go to boston and get
expedited legal status and jobs didn't
take them to boston took him to martha's
vineyard and that is why there is now a
civil suit the story that marco rubio
and republicans are telling
doesn't have any truth to it i mean
it they're mentioning that some of the
migrants are from venezuela and that's
true right i mean if we want to find
something that is accurate so
they are lying
and we should be aware of that but
unfortunately the lies spread like
wildfire
one of our sponsors is helix sleep i
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
for years and i always recommend it to
friends you'd simply take this helix
sleep quiz it asks you about your body
type your sleep position whether you
have back pain and then helix will match
you up with the mattress that is
personalized to your needs and they ship
it to you for free another reason i went
with helix is that unlike a lot of
mattress companies out there every
single helix mattress is made in the usa
by a skilled production team which means
when you buy a helix mattress you're
supporting great jobs i'm not the only
one who loves helix helix was recently
awarded number one mattress by both gq
and wired magazine every helix mattress
comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty you
can try it a hundred nights and send it
back for a full refund if you need to
support the david pakman show by getting
your next mattress from helix sleep and
you'll get up to three hundred and fifty
dollars off any mattress plus two free
pillows when you go to helix sleep.com
pacman the link is down below